Hey what's going on is Bill Byrne time
for the Monday morning podcast for Monday.
Monday Monday May 29 2017.
What's going on. Are you
home. How are you guys doing.
Happy Memorial Day.
When you're supposed to be out there
remembering the troops you're gonna be
getting a ham
and say bad shit to your wife that you
later apologize for what's going on you
fuckin soon to be fat fucks.
You got to you got the grill
going back and they right.
We are a little Calabash.
What are you guys making today huh.
What fucking animal how to get
the old right there Fred you know.
And an uppercut to another one you're
fuckin sodium together What in God's name
do you have on your grill right now that
you know you're fucking what you put in
there bunch of cheese
who wants cheese in their burger.
Come on seats are going to fucking burn.
Carrie.
Oh you know it's the best.
You put the buns on.
That's that's the you know you keep
Jack and keep checking me looking at the
meat. They want to burn the
buns. Christ they burn this one.
That's right.
Yeah well I think way burn.
I bet she swallows. I'm
sorry sir. Why Bill Why.
Why did you have to take the nice family
day that this is you know that the
great men of this country fought so you
could go out there you know work slowly
work your way take another step
towards a fucking massive coronary.
How many people are gonna face
plant to their grill today.
Veal.
Too much alcohol.
You know just eat that last thing that
fuckin makes the ticker stop or you know
the classic old fuckin middle aged man
injury that fuckin blown out Achilles you
know.
Oh did you say you wanted pickles you
just turn a little too fast and pound shit
goes right up the back leg then you face
plant right do you fuckin grill side of
the face right.
You'd be surprised I bet if I could
somehow get some sort of lives.
You know phones in here I bet my phone
lines would be lighting up right now with
paramedics fire department people
people that drive ambulances
is the driver of the ambulance do you
actually have to know how to help people
are you just like the guy the getaway
driver you know all you need to do is not
to turn on the siren you
won't be able to block it out.
You think ambulance drivers hear that
siren at night it's a late night quiet
bedroom you know trying to put fucking
music on cause they don't they're just
laying there all year
slowly going insane
I don't know I'm in a great fuckin
mood you know my lovely little Lay is
starting to sleep through the night I'm
starting to get some sleep again dude
she's hilarious she just does this thing
now she's trying out a voice she just
goes guy like it loud as shit laying in
the bed in the morning between me and
this just that. It's like fucking
a little mini Jerry Lewis.
The entire time it's
so I just put my hand over my mouth I
just I just make it go away I think and
then she kind of like looks around like
What the fuck was that and that stops
for about four seconds before she starts
again and then she gets used to the
noise and then that's it.
She started to crawl she's fucking moving
backwards it's funny like that I guess
they move backwards first so it's
like the thing that they want.
It just keeps getting further and further
away like that Alfred Hitchcock shot.
But anyways I had family from back east
out here this weekend which means plenty
of booze plenty of fucking crazy food.
So I've been doing the elliptical every
day doing what I can but you know this
is like at this point everybody is gonna
come out here has come out here they've
all seen are they all lover and
what's awesome is now I don't have to
I realize now when people visit me they're
not coming to see me which is fucking
awesome they're coming to see
her oh Hey Bill how you doing.
Where is she. Where is she. She'll
be all would you look at her.
Look at her it's great.
And you just peel off in the back you
know all your family members come over the
new year I'll get to hold her and stuff
you know so then you get to sit there
boozing in the corner.
Happy holidays. Now it's
been great. She's awesome.
She's so awesome I'm not getting
any fucking material out of it
everyone was telling me oh my god you're
having a kid I can't wait for you to
become a dad.
Oh my God I want to see how
your act changes. It hasn't.
I'm still paranoid I'm still filthy
and my daughter is awesome. So.
You know that's not funny.
I know it's like being a
dad. It's great. Phenomenal.
I think most my material is just
about other fucking lunatic parents.
I'm telling you what I'm going to start
saying to people when they go Oh she's
the Oh yeah that's a great H I'll wait
wait til 3 days from now then all well
you've done she's gonna love she'll
and start stabbing you in the night.
I mean you don't start
saying those parents.
I'm just gonna be like you know
you sound like a horrible father and
I think you married the wrong person.
Have a nice day.
How you could look at this experience
in a negative way is fucking look if
you're broke.
If you're a kid if you're a fucking high
school student right and you know you
started banging your goddamn English
teacher and yet you didn't know enough to
pull out as much as they told you in
sex education how much you know how a
baby's made you couldn't fucking believe
you a bang and your English teacher and
the next thing you know you're going to
be a fart Yeah. Then then it's brutal.
You know if you're married to this fucking
old broad is always correct in your
fucking sentences.
You know.
You're calling around for dressing like
a whore and she's fucking giving you
shit for for a dangling participle
whatever the fuck I never knew what that
meant.
The past participle
Bell was a past participle
this sentence I don't know.
Just send me to summer school just gimme
gimme in that fuckin distilled version
of this class that is nothing.
That dream team of class clowns that
is summer school drug addicts and
musicians. It was just fucking
tremendous summer school.
Underrated I tell you.
I went. I did it twice.
I should have done it all four years of
high school but I blew off the last year
because what was the fucking point.
My sophomore year my teacher
hooked me up gave me the D minus
D minus and geometry
I fucking had a great time. I had a
great time I tend to take one class.
You don't get me out
of bed in the morning.
In summer school was combined like three
towns where I lived and it was a it was
all the class clowns.
Just like I said creative people everybody
had a D and the level of shit that
they gave to the teacher I was
like why I got to up my game.
These people are on a whole nother level.
So when you go to jail you
become like a better criminal.
I became a better class clown just sit
there like well these guys are fucking
these guys I have no intention of going
to college Emily still lying to myself I
think I could you know
I think I could go in the later rounds
if you were a fucking draft pick.
Be honest with yourself you were a high
school student What round are you going
and do you know and if you really think
about it that's why Bill Belichick he
doesn't like the first round draft picks
because the first round draft picks
they like book smart right there the
fucking nerds you know you give him some
information they'll memorize it and spit
it right back at you right there's no
passion
they they they they don't walk into a
room and light it up is a bad analogy
because first round draft
picks do I guess do they
I don't know about college basketball
now with everybody one and done
you bring this fucking kid to a locker
room full of men and put the team on his
back bony fucking legs
Well Bill what are they supposed to do
a lot of them you know it's like their
mothers you know they they need a new
kidney and the shack they live in is
falling the bucket.
Fair enough.
But selfishly as a fan you know you miss
the days when somebody had four years
with fucking Coach K or
Dean Smith rest his soul.
Bobby Knight flip it I mean the chant
stopped looking down fucking there.
David I've told them before they it much
I fucking love that Bobby Knight speech
where he says you know I'm
not going to you're not going.
I'm not gonna walk around with a 40 to 20.
I don't know what it is about that guy.
Listen to that speech and
it makes me want to go fuck.
I don't know if I'll go to the
gym after listening to that guy.
Something happened you know when
that guy got ran out of town.
That was that was it. You
know. Then all of a sudden like
guys stared into just literally being
pussies like fuck and wearing shirts with
cats on him and stuff.
You know.
My wife was showing me that look there's
a men's onesie that's out there now
that guy's aware and I was like
You've gotta be fucking kidding.
Like when is it going to stop. When is
it going to steer back to testosterone.
When is the guys guy
going to make a comeback.
I mean everything makes a comeback right.
Classic rock disco hair metals
make it a little bit of a comeback.
I don't fucking know.
I just don't get it.
And in some ways show me what they were
like Sean Connery wore one in one of the
James Bond movies and it's like all right.
But he wasn't wearing it like
he thought it looked good.
He wasn't wearing it because
it was fucking stupid.
You know that's what
I can't fucking stand.
Everything's like Mark and
something else it's like all right.
So what do you believe in.
What are you gonna fuck him sign your name
to and these fucking millennial cunts.
Oh I can't say all of them.
That's not fair to a whole generation.
But so the ones that at least have taken
pictures of OK which granted most of
these pictures are being taken care taken
by older people from my generation who
are jealous of younger people.
That's what a lot of it is.
I bet I bet I'm overreacting
when I really think about it.
I don't really see a lot of
people with cats. On their shirts.
Although when they do people take pictures
of them then they post them on social
media and then old fucks like me start
going Oh look these fucking millennials
they're fucking.
It's a scratch all of it.
I mean really Bill.
Have you seen anybody with a onesie.
Some we just showed you a picture and
then you literally started freaking out
like you watch CNN or
Fox News for two hours.
That's always a great thing to do watch
those for a couple two three hours and
they get you all panicked what you want
to do is you want to switch between the
two of them right.
And then you balance out the lies
and you keep yourself level headed.
You know fake news tell fake news.
So anyways I want to be like
that I want to be that guy okay.
God bless you millennials. I'm sure this
there's plenty of guys guys on the way.
You're out there fucking crush an ass.
God bless you.
Join your youth Joy your fucking youth
before it's Memorial Day and suddenly
you're that guy with the dad bod standing
in front of the grill filling that
tightness in your Achilles you know you've
got to reach for that last burger in
the back of the fuckin grill.
You just start feeling that
tightness in your ankle you like.
If it's going to happen please
don't let it happen now.
Not in front of my family back east.
Nobody has guessed the movie by
the way that I am referring to.
We had problems with the family back east.
This I was gonna say I'd give you a
hint but this isn't really hard in my
opinion that movie.
It's a car movie
for me.
I just feel like that
movie is a car movie.
Other people thought there was
some philosophical question
you know who's to fly
who's the windshield.
All I remember from that
movie was I loved the car.
Because I love a fuckin sleek
I remember the car that was a sleeper
and then I just remembered that there was
this one guy.
Was having problems with the family
back east and that explained his entire
fucking backstory
that's it now.
If you guys can't guess it now I
don't know what the fuck. I don't.
I don't know what to tell you.
All right they had a fuckin pizza.
Yeah. Can I get a guy get a sausage
in a rubella. We got an old rule.
You know me Rubio. Yeah. We had family
we planned up the family back east.
It will give us a Ruger
anyway. So what you guys do this weekend
other sit around. You know what I did.
I watched somebody tweeted me on the
old Twitter and told me are you watching
the time trials for Monaco. And here's
the thing. I know I'm new to F1.
She goes No I can barely
remember the fucking names.
So I'm like I'm I'm gonna like it.
I had no idea like how
they qualify for a race.
I just thought you know you get like five
laps around the track whoever has the
best time gets the pole position and
then they just work their way back.
But that that that is not how it works.
It's like a whole other day of racing
because I was one like Why the fuck did
people show up to watch
these these qualifying
Remy. Just watch some guy
by himself out there. Yeah.
Yeah he is gonna be in
eighth place tomorrow.
That's not how it works.
It is the race before the race and it's
like there's three race so there's three
levels of the qualifying. There's
like first of all this practice laps.
Get used to the track and if you don't
do the practice laps you're not allowed
to race so obviously it's probably some
safety thing like Dude you're not just
gonna fucking go out there and
start driving 20 miles an hour.
It's this next one a
right or a left turn share
qualifying OK.
So there's just like three rounds of it.
So qualifying the first round one.
It's like March Madness but with
cars it lasts for 18 minutes.
Everybody gets on the fucking track.
I'm sure they don't turn up they let six
out and another six I how fast they do
it I miss that part of it OK but it
lasts for 18 minutes at the end of which
time. Can you tell I'm reading this the
sixth slowest drivers are eliminated from
qualifying and 16 advance
to q t the qualifying 2 so
those six are gonna be that
then I thought oh my be out of the fuckin
race is this like golf or you missed
the cut.
And I found out later No they
just start way in the back.
OK so
so there's 22 fucking drivers I guess
so let's see so six of them are fucking
eliminated but I think usually 20 drivers
to to not have to go home I have no
idea if anybody knows the information
to that I don't know if anybody if you
don't move to the next round of qualifying
if anybody actually doesn't get to
race because I thought there was 20 cars
in the race and according to this mass
there's twenty two or whatever so six
or eliminated in the first one then the
next sixteen you know after a short
break the times are reset and the sixteen
remaining cars run in a 15 minute session.
So now we're down to 15.
And at the end of which the slowest
six cars are eliminated from qualifying
leaving tend to progress
to qualifying three.
Now the top ten spots after the race those
that that's when you're in the points
from first all the way to 10th it's like
some like twenty five points for first
18 for second then it's like
15 then 12 10 8 6 4 2 1.
Are the points
you're in the you're in the fucking
lightning round at that point.
And then whoever you are obviously
has the best run after that gets the.
Qualifying three after a further break.
Times are reset in the final 12 minutes
session is held to decide pole position
and the standing order of
the top 10 grid places.
That's when you're in
the points all right.
That's when you're going home with least
with the fucking year supply of rice a
roni. If you're in the top 10. So
I watched it because somebody on Twitter
is like Dude you gotta watch this.
This might be better than the race.
So Lewis Hamilton.
From the Isle of Man.
It's an island with men nothing but men.
All walking around like right
where the Falcon lays the birds.
Whatever the fuck they
call them over the flags.
Anyways.
He's out there he's got Mercedes he's
got one of the fastest fuckin cars out
there but for whatever fucking reason
he's not getting enough downward force or
something on the front of his car
in the front end is sliding all over
everywhere so he barely gets
out of qualifying when he
gets into qualifying too.
And it's there's a 50 minute session
and he's outside of qualifying to get to
the next level.
His time is too slow so he's
got time to do one more run.
OK now he's in second
place overall for the
for the to become champ to stand.
To stay on pace to be whatever the fuck
and best drive with you. I'm sorry guys.
I'm new to this fucking thing
and his fucking front and starts sliding
all over the place and then some cunt
hits the wall.
So then the yellow flag comes out and
I guess that doesn't matter if some
asshole drives into the fucking wall.
You're qualifying time has
done this fucking idiot
he's a professional driver.
He hits the wall and he hit the wall.
I get it.
You know they said they actually
put some special staring at.
They make custom steering just for that
fuckin track in Monaco because they're
just driving through the streets and
they have such a hairpin turn that they
actually have to turn the wheel
harder than they do at any other race.
You know why when they just leave that in
when you want to have that option.
Case she had to drive all the way around
something at some point in the other
races.
Evidently not.
So anyways long story short this fucking
guy I think from Force India with the
future car just basically you know he
pulls the Greg babe Brady you know gotta
beat Marsha getting a call closer than
a quarter of an inch he fuckin slams
right into the wall and then that's it.
And Lewis Hamilton was so fucking dejected
he couldn't even get out of his car.
You know and long story short the
fucking Ferrari's a fucked is my god damn
computer.
Keep doing this to me
trying to get the screen to
come up can you stay up dog.
I sit there fingering the
fuckin thing the whole time.
Yeah so long story short the Ferrari's
won the first and second position.
And I think that Brutus guy the
finished dude started in third and Lewis
Hamilton was all the way back in 14th
so he's out of the points and you're
driving through the fucking streets
of Monaco a sovereign state.
In other words they're in France but
they're not part of France like you have
fuck off.
We're doing our own thing here and
I guess it's really hard to pass there.
But despite that the fuckin race starts.
Immediately.
He went from 14th to 12th and I'm
watching the race and I'm like This
motherfucker.
He's probably going to finish fourth.
He's somehow gonna figure some
he's gonna fuck up in the Pit Stop.
Something's gonna happen so I'm watching
the whole time I'm watching the race
and I'm watching and he's 12 and he's
11th then he's 10th and the fucking
announcers are blowing it off because
they're too busy looking at that what the
Ferrari's are gonna do.
What the Red Bull teams doing what the
fuck are boo tasks he's gonna be doing in
the Mercedes and meanwhile he's Lewis
Hamilton just moving at this is the
longest ever talked about race and it's
got to feel people like dude I don't
give a fuck you driving
around in a circle.
No they're not then I try and run there's
left and right turns all right there's
a chicane.
Dude you least gotta watch Monaco you
shouldn't watch Monaco with the fucking
Illuminati people fucking back their
yachts up although I went online and I
found like you can actually there's a
lot of them were just like packages like
those aren't just rich people with their
yards backed up there's just a lot of
like booze cruises and you can sit
there on a fucking yard getting hammered
acting like you didn't just light up
your fucking credit card whatever Stacey
will deal with it when we
get back we get baggage.
So long story short on a track that you
could not fuckin pass on somehow Lewis
passed seven fucking people
finished seventh so let's
see that's 1 2 he got like
6 points or something like that and
the Ferrari's came in first and second.
All right Sebastian Vettel ended up
winning after a great fuckin pit stop and
what's his face.
Kimi Raikkonen is at his fucking name.
Raking in or whatever finish
dude Sebastian's the crowd.
The German dude he fucking comes out of
the pit before he hit Kimi going like
What the fuck.
He said to like make somebody cut me
off in traffic but he's driving like 170
miles an hour.
What's his face. Daniel always a
bridesmaid never a fucking winner.
Ricardo came in fucking third the guy's
always on the podium never comes in
first he's gotta be pissed
like guys what the fuck
can you do somebody the car here so I
can get past these Ferraris and Mercedes
and I want oil and I got a deal here.
So long story short Ferrari is a team has
one hundred ninety six points Mercedes
has one hundred seventy nine and the
Americans the Yanks just to let you know
we're pulling up the rear.
We got our first points of the season
what do we got we got Romain like the
lettuce grass Gene he got nine points and
then Kevin Magnussen like the condoms got
five so we got 14 points so just those
Ferrari's Mercedes better mind their
fuckin p's and q's because the Yanks are
coming. All right thank you for fuckin
sitting through all of that shit.
Let's talk about Tiger Woods.
Jesus fucking Christ
can you believe he got arrested
for drinking and driving.
It only happens to nine zillion
people every fucking day.
I'm so sick of people talking about
Tiger Woods like the way they disrespect
this guy.
You know I love Stephen A Smith but I
started watching him talking and he was
saying that you know that you know this
guy's just his fall from basically his
fall from grace.
And
now his whole you know he
became a billionaire and
his whole fucking thing was
based on the fact that he
presented himself as a family man.
And I'm thinking like when.
When the fuck did he ever
present himself as a family man.
Did he get to where the fuck he was
because he was the best golfer anybody had
ever seen
because he was making like PGA fucking
links look like like he was playing
miniature golf.
I never pay attention to
that fucking Blondie was Why
don't you do a fucking name
that area.
So he bangs a bunch of Hooters whores and
then I'm spot then I'm supposed to sit
on the couch go on.
He lied to me Tiger.
I thought after you golf you fucking
went down to Applebee's with your family
and fucking your family back east and
you shared a fucking bloomin onion.
I have to be honest with you I never
once thought about what the fuck that guy
did when he got off the golf course and
when I found out what he was doing off
the golf course I was like Yeah
I mean that kind of makes sense
I am to say it's the amount of fuckin
men okay when Stephen A Smith walks out.
Of his studio you know he doesn't have
a line of whores just waiting to fucking
blow him just so they can
say I blew Stephen A Smith.
Tiger Woods had to deal with that.
And like most men he
folded under the pressure.
And the fucking reason why.
He's not doing well right now it's not
because of his fucking wife who by the
way took a bunch of his money bought a
house fuck and knocked it down and then
rebuilt another one.
What about her.
I thought she was
right.
What about her.
What about all Blondie right there.
I still a bit about this do you think
she would even give Tiger Woods a second
fucking glance if he wasn't making all
that money if he wasn't the greatest at
what he did.
Would all blond blue eyed even give that
guy a fuckin second I don't think she
would have.
All right.
Even when you're a bum like me when you
fucking walked in the singles bar back
in the 90s what did women
always say what do you do.
They're not making small talk.
Okay women all fucking judge okay.
Their status. And then they get a
number in their head. All right.
And then they find out the jobs
okay that earn this and earn that.
And then they figure it like
who they can fuck. Okay.
And then it becomes a thing of like OK
you're underneath what I want for the
lifestyle.
That I'm looking for in the future but
you're a good looking enough guy that
I'll fuckin bang it tonight.
Maybe I'll have a little fling with you.
But that's going the
end of the fucking day.
You know when you slid that piece of
paper across the table and you made your
offer say my dick and balls bring
home this each year they're like Yeah.
Keep it moving keep it moving.
That's that's ten grand less than I want.
And you got that one snagged too.
Fuck off. Move on. Who's next. Gad put
your junk on the table what's your number.
And he has it any is a thing.
I don't fault women for that.
Who wants to live like a bum. If you're
good and if you're good looking enough.
OK. And you can land somebody
that's making a ton of fuckin money.
You can learn to love that right.
I don't know.
So anyways now he gets busted for drinking
and driving. This is the bottom line.
This fucking guy's fall from grace.
OK.
All right I'll give you the first fucking
couple of years after his divorce.
Like maybe that got in his fucking head
but at the end I mean you can't get
divorced ten fucking years ago.
What happened was was his marriage and
his body broke down at the same fucking
time. But I just had major back
surgeries knees of fucked up.
And they always said they said back
when everybody thought he was the family
band back east that the way that the level
of talk and the pressure that was put
on his back. They predicted his body
was gonna break down and it did.
And then when it does you know now
they're going to blame you know
it's the classic ladies just
taking credit. That's all it is.
They always take it behind
every great man is a good woman.
You know they're okay.
All right is it I don't.
I mean what's your definition of great
I mean
but every great man is a great woman.
It's like the guy was already
a fucking champion when he met.
So if you're talking about
his mother I'll give you that.
But this whole fucking thing or now.
I mean Jesus I can tell you his mug shot.
That's a classic one.
I'd like to have a couple
of pops of Tiger back
alley.
Yeah.
He needs this is what he needs to do.
He needs to hit the fuckin
treadmill all right.
And he's got to shave his fucking
head already. You gotta let that go.
Oh God. He comes to Monday morning
it comes to him. Photoshop.
Can you please photoshop
my fucking head underneath.
Tiger Woods is mug an air.
God you know it's funny is he
looks like he's fuckin wasted.
But you know what he's saying
he's looking into the camera.
Gone well I know a billion
people are going to see this.
What the fuck are they
going to say about this one.
I don't I can't even
begin to tell you guys.
I. I can't. Are you kidding.
Begins I guess how bad I want to
see this guy win a major again.
Look at this. Editors Pick the secret
history of Tiger Woods. Now how.
How much do you think they
actually talk to Tiger Woods
so the death of his father set a battle
raging inside the world's greatest
golfer.
Dish dish.
How the fuck do you know why.
Because you talked to his gardener said
the closest you could get to him an egg
and write 400 pages of bullshit.
Listen do me a favor don't listen
any of this stuff okay. He's a man.
He makes mistakes. He's in the public
eye. I hope his back gets better.
You know what.
I hope he goes out like fucking who's
that guy used to fucking to sit there.
The big deal that put the blonde
hair and he's fucking sit there.
I think you played Oliver on the
Brady Bunch way back in the day.
Then when he grew up he became this drunk.
He was this alcoholic fuckin he
he hit the ball a fuckin mile.
God damn it it's gonna kill
me I gotta look this up here
alcoholic golfer.
Driver
long and so I search and
John Daly there we go.
Bam. Nailed it. John.
You know I hope it comes
back like a combination. Like
I don't know a Terminator and John Daly.
That's what I want.
I want a fuckin drunk cyborg going out
there and I hope he fuckin passes Jack
Nicholas.
And just you know I don't understand
people that look at people in the public
eye to the point that
they they disappoint them.
You know get a fucking life
Jesus Christ.
What was a fuckin movie.
Captain Kirk when he did he did the
sketch talking to the Trekkies on SNL.
Get a fucking life.
You know guys.
I don't know.
I don't if you notice the last couple of
weeks I've been a little and I've been
a little down you know and I know the
podcast hasn't been as good as it has been
in the past and it's just because
you know I feel like
Tiger Woods let me down.
You know all those times I've never
met him or even remotely spoken to him.
You know I just really thought we had
something there and for him to turn around
and go back on his word that he never
gave me because I've never spoken with
them that just I was devastated and.
I'm not going to be able
to come into work today.
Man I hope that guy wins
another fucking Major.
I can't even tell you I
can't I can't even fucking.
I just didn't tell you didn't they.
I think I just did tell you
last week I was talking
about helicopters and
you know I know some pilots listen to
this fucking thing you know mass pumping
all that shit you have to deal with
low g pushover with a fuckin semi
articulated rotor system does anybody
know about these fucking these these new
European helicopters that are starting
to be available over here and he has a
fully articulated rotor system set up
to deal with any of that shit and a fuel
injected so there's no do
I need to pull carb heat.
Am I going to fucking die here.
I don't know to say gee you
I MBA l gamble Aubrey G to.
And I wrote next to it what's the deal.
I talked to two of my instructors one
of them said hey that's pretty cool that
they do that.
The other one said Well it's kind of
like remember when the first iPhone came
out because they're brand new.
Then they had to work all the bugs out.
He said they learned about
aircraft through people crashing.
That's right. Fuck those things. Then
anyways you know.
You know I was thinking.
I think one of these days when I would
do it I'm just gonna buy a used Apache
you know or whatever the fuck they have
those black hawks is some shit I'm just
gonna learn how to fly that and then
I'm just going to join those Blackwater
dudes. That's my apocalypse
thing. You know what I mean.
I'm not gonna learn how to kill people.
I think like that I'll
just be the shuttle guy.
I'll take you back from the frontlines
back to base base camp and I'll just sit
there eat my soup.
That's my game plan.
All right let's read some of the fucking
advertising here for this week which of
course I didn't even did even look
this shit up yet. No I didn't.
I apologize for this. You know I just
it's just Tiger Woods let me down.
You know I thought he was a family member
and I mean I haven't been this fucking
I haven't been this fucking distraught.
Since Michael Jordan's acceptance speech
at the Hall of Fame when I found out
who he really was I mean I was devastated
and I just remember all those times I
had not hung out with Michael
Jordan or ever talked to him.
I just feel like he really just
you know I just thought
he was better than that.
I love that when he gave that speech
and everyone's like wait a minute this
guy's like fucking got ice water in his
veins and he's he's got a mean streak in
him.
It's like yeah yeah
all those fuckin people who
had never picked a gym class.
They were like Oh this is why I sucked.
It wasn't just that I was uncoordinated
I didn't have this killer fucking
instinct.
He went after his own god damn kids you
know and that's what it takes. All right.
Me on the are of those though
beyond days beyond days.
Michael Jordan's fuckin long shorts.
Doo doo doo doo.
My young days me on D Day that long
because it was dark he's fuckin 6 6 so is
his dick but his balls were off until
he got me on D and then he made the Hall
of Fame he finally beat the fucking
Pistons because his piston was nice and
fuckin soft with me on D
What about Bill Walton.
All right pride starts on the inside.
So celebrate yourself with me on D Mondays
makes the ultimate feel good undies
with free shipping right to your door.
Satisfaction guaranteed all right.
Designed in L.A.
Louisiana Los Angeles.
Every pair of me undies is made with
micro modal model of fabric three times
softer than copy.
You know it's true because you have
never heard the cotton lobby ever debated
their soft stretchy undies come in
every ever changing array of colors and
patterns no matter what your style.
They got some for you.
That's because beyond these believes in
people feeling good and being themselves.
Which is why me undies.
Why me undies is putting their money where
their underwear is during Pride month
for every pair of special edition
celebrate undies you buy during Pride me
undies during Pride Sari me undies will
donate one dollar to the Los Angeles
LGBT Center.
You fear pandering to your audience.
You got a bunch of colorful underwear
right. I see what's going on.
You get did a little algorithm well more
gay people than straights are buying
these.
You know we all.
Maybe we got one maybe gay
people by the gay people.
Gay guys I bet gay guys buy more underwear
more underwear than straight guys do
you know because women are so fucking
forgiving. Right but guys it's so visual.
So maybe gay guys are like I just feel a
pressure that I always have to have new
underwear on because I just feel so I
just feel like for me when somebody sees
my dick and bawl.
First I want to have a brand new
pair of me undies. Good for them.
Good for them.
I bet if you looked up a bet that's true.
Generally speaking gay men have newer
cleaner underwear than a straight guy
right. Anyways as if you needed
another reason to try me on this.
They're offering 20 percent off your
first pair and a satisfaction guarantee
that you'll you'll love them
or your money back. Just visit.
Are you Are you are l me undies dot com
slash per head to me on these today and
pick up a pair of special
editions celebrate undies.
You'll not only get a discount of
awesome Mondays you'll be donating to an
amazing cause.
Checkout me on undies dot com slash bar
today I want to know when you're going
to come out with the Caitlyn Jenner's you
know you guys ought to do it like like
how basketball sneakers do it they'll
pick like you know they got Jordans they
got the Kobe's you know and after that
game 7 you know you know what's coming
out next October the Olynyk once every
white guy with the dream gonna be buying
those they ought to do
that with me on this.
You know you got to have the Tiger Woods.
Tiger Woods me undies to Caitlyn
Jenner's WHO ELSE IS BE A GOOD PERSON THE
FUCKING
MONEY up with Ric Flair you
gotta get the RIC flares.
Down it's a whole new market for
you guys all right Blue Apron.
Not only not okay not all
ingredients are created equal.
Oh Jesus Christ thick fucking governors
they make America great again it's not
all and creeds are created equal Yeah
fresh high quality ingredients make a real
difference.
Oh really.
Fresh high quality agrees. Make a
real difference when you're cooking.
Oh I could just pull
some out of the trash.
These Blue Apron guys you're
always learning something
anyway so it's important
to know where your food comes from.
Really.
I just I just thought I could keep eating
fucking cows that were fed other cows.
Talk about your personal experience
with Blue Apron. I've never used it.
Additional copy points feature as desired.
OK this is all this is all optional.
Well I'll go right to the end then.
Blue Apron a better way to cook.
Now I can't do that. All right.
Additional Cook affordable.
OK.
Well for all you people are upside down
in your house out there you know and
nobody gives a shit.
You still want to eat well for less
than ten dollars per person per meal.
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with pre ingredients to make
delicious home cooked meals.
Variety choose from a variety.
The Tiger Woods the Tiger
Woods option here variety.
If you'd want to come over
the same fucking mashed
potatoes and every once in a
while you want to have a little plug
and have a go again for less than 10
dollars per person per meal.
Sorry it's wrong to choose from a variety
of new recipes each week or they blue
aprons. Culinary team
surprise you. Holy shit.
Recipes are not repeated within a year
so you'll never get bored guaranteed blue
aprons freshness guarantees promise
that every ingredient in your delivery
arrives ready to cook or
they'll make it right.
Check out this week's menu and get the
first three meals for free with free
shipping by going to Blue
Apron dot com slash br.
Blue Apron dot com slash bar Blue Apron.
A better way to cook.
And lastly but certainly not least the
R Dollar Shave Club look at them with a
nice fucking quick copy.
They understand they understand
my difficulties Dollar
Shave Club is the smarter
choice you'll get a great shave at a great
price conveniently delivered right to
your door.
They have all the jerseys they had this
deal is the Shaq's the charges and more.
Sorry that was the voice I just remembered
from MVP sports that read from way
back in the day when they didn't want
to hire somebody professional they just
hired some fucking hot chick that the
owner was probably bang and like Tiger
Woods but he hasn't won a golf
tournament so nobody knows right.
Anyway you no longer have to schlep to
the store buy a cheap disposable fucking
razor.
That gives you a choice. OK. Buy educate.
What you no longer have to schlep to the
store to buy a cheap disposable razor
that gave you a cheap shave or spend a
fortune on razors with gimmickry shaving
technology you didn't need and when you
use Doc Dollar Shave clubs executive
razor with Doctor carving.
Blade gently glides
giving you a smooth shave.
Dr. carver shaved butter is transparent.
For a more precise shave helps prevent
ingrown hairs and fights razor bumps make
the smarter choice by
joining Dollar Shave Club.
Do you know the people at Dollar Shave
Club at a custom Doctor Carville's easy
shave but a tube that they framed.
Andrew finally was able to
convince me to take the thing.
He goes it gave you something I'm like I
don't want any more shit I got too much
shit. Then he goes now you gotta see this
thing and like fucking a year later I
finally got it from my God damn it.
It's another thing I gotta put up on
the wall. Someday explain to people.
Oh I have mild dyslexia and I thought Dr.
Carver's Shea butter said Dr. Carver's
easy shaped butter and
I used to scream it.
It's like Gee Bill do you have any more
boring stories framed on your wall.
Yes yes I do.
OK.
Make the smart choice by joining
dollar shave club for a limited time.
New members can get their first month of
the executive razor with a tube of the
doctor.
You have easy for only five
dollars with free shipping.
After that razors are
just a few bucks a month.
That's a 15 dollar value
for only five bucks.
There are no hidden fees no commitments
cancel anytime you like you can only get
this offer exclusively a dark dollar shave
club dot com slash burn that's Dollar
Shave Club dot com slash bar are
right 44 minutes in just like that.
OK.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S READ THESE FUCKING let's read
these fucking questions here. All right.
Europe Hi.
That's it. I like it short and sweet.
Been a huge fan of Bill for many years.
Are there any plans for a touring
Europe specifically the Netherlands.
Would love to see him perform live.
Well I was there last year man if you
were a fan for many years you should have
checked my Web site. I think I'm
going to go to Europe next year.
And I'll probably build it around
a couple of F1 races possibly I don't
know what I'm going to go over there but
I'm definitely due to do a run
I've got a bunch of new shit but you know
I have to make sure it's at a certain
level before I go over there because
Europe loves to just have critics show up
at shows without you know the artists
saying hey can you review this show you
know and they review it anyway and they
take out their fucking goddamn steak
knives and they cover
up every fucking time.
So I always make sure I'm on my game here.
All right girl who stabbed boyfriend
isn't walking free. OK here we go.
This is the new this is new part of the
podcast everybody fucking correct and
old Bill you know.
That's why I made sure to fucking look
up all my my F1 shit you know cause you
goddamn cunt girl who stabbed boyfriend
I have a prediction about the Red Sox
too by the way which I will get to
later on hopefully if I remember.
All right that's a teaser and I might
let you down I might disappoint you like
Michael Jordan like fucking Tiger Woods
you know all that entertainment that
they gave you when they watch when you
get to watch them doing things that have
never been done before.
All right girl who stabbed
boyfriend isn't walking free.
Okay so this story was about
some lady at Oxford two fucking.
I don't know what the hell she did she
stabbed her boyfriend in the leg with a
bread knife and blah blah blah blah blah.
And I think I was like Well
I know you have. You know
you have all this fucking you know
potential and all this type of shit.
So this person.
This person is writing back saying
she is going through what's.
I realize you like to make the excuse
that we shouldn't expect you to do any
actual research on stories you
talk about and that's fine.
Well then you should leave it at that sir.
But in this particular story you ranted
on Thursday's part. I didn't rant.
I'm joking around.
You're fucking overreacting cunts.
Do you guys understand what a rant is.
Read to me is short for ranting and raving
so you've got a borderline have froth
coming out of your fucking mouth.
Joking around about a subject for five
minutes is not a fucking rant is stupid
fuck.
God damn it.
All right.
So even like right there.
To me that's just I just fucking
fucking wigged out for a second there.
But a ray rant.
Ok.
On Thursday you didn't even you didn't
even need to do research to see how wrong
you were again.
I'm not wrong.
I'm being funny.
Fuck that Oxford girl isn't getting
off free because she's white.
Oh my God.
As the lovely Nia proposed and not
because she's a woman as the freckled BA
literate bird suggested she
isn't getting off at all in fact.
It's said right in the article you reading
that she was going to be sentenced in
September and has been
giving a restraining order.
Yeah I saw that and I also
read the fucking judges quote.
I looked it up and I read along with your
pockets. Sentencing was only postpone.
She isn't getting out of jail time yet.
Yeah but don't you find it fucked up
what you can address the fact that the
judge said You're so talented I don't
wanna derail your fucking what you could
possibly achieve.
You don't think that's
weird for him to say that
you don't think race and
gender affects your sentencing.
You don't think that you don't think
that any day that there's all this racism
there's all this sexism and all that
but in the court of law there isn't.
There isn't status there isn't you're
at Oxford versus you're just somebody on
the street you stab somebody
with a fucking knife.
You don't think that any of
that comes into play sir.
So anyways he says if you ask me which
it didn't I think this is a good thing.
If she is as bright as the people at the
schools say she is she can definitely
do a lot of good in her career.
In sentencing her for a
one off would ruin that.
So you're agreeing with this guy.
Oh my God this is fucking hilarious.
You're sitting there saying that I'm not.
That's basically what it is.
It's not that I was misinformed.
OK.
It's that you agreed with the judge.
He said that being said she needs to
be held responsible. So what is it.
Seeing as if it was only a butter knife
I think mandatory anger management
classes is an order at the very least.
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
Come back to Madison. You were great
last time. Go fuck yourself again sir.
She stabs somebody with a knife.
Let me let that sink in.
She stabs someone with a fucking knife
but because she goes to Oxford and she
could be a doctor
you're out of your fucking mind.
You're just like the judge you're like
oh look at her she's a girl she's doing
so well in school she looks like me.
It was just a bread knife.
You're doing what they're doing.
In a perfect world sir.
Stabbing somebody with a knife and the
punishment is stabbing someone with a
knife. In the punishment.
And that's fucking it.
Go watch said fucking trap car thing or
whatever the fuck they call it with a
pocket down in the
fucking poor neighborhood.
They rest one black eye
after fucking another
I mean that's they're not
trying to help anybody.
You don't think anybody
down there has potential.
You just gonna say it's gonna
fucking do that to them.
Why do they just do why they don't
why don't they do than a fucking white
neighborhood.
Mike I don't know. I don't I just
don't see the world the way you do sir.
And you see it the way that judge does.
And I also think that you are like what
you're taking into consideration which
is is the fact that she's at
Oxford and she could be a doctor.
You're completely and you're
now downplaying that she
stabbed someone and yes
you are sir.
Yes you are because you said she should
take anger management classes at the
very least
like you might call me fucking overly
liberal but if you stab someone you should
go to jail.
Regardless of what your potential is
Do you realize that this woman if she
becomes a surgeon will have a knife in
her hand every fucking day of her goddamn
career just about and it won't
be a fucking butter knife.
Jesus fucking Christ and when she goes
to cut somebody open and then finds out
that they have state insurance rather
than private What the fuck is she going to
do then
just because you go to Oxford doesn't
mean you couldn't be a fucking lunatic.
You don't know me.
And people in those schools commit
murders and they do commit crimes but they
don't go to jail the way poorer
people with more of a tan do.
I don't know if you've noticed that.
So for us to bring up the fact that
she was a woman and that she was white.
Was not we were not uninformed.
We're actually more than I actually you
know I'm going to pat myself on the back
I'm more fucking enlightened than you are.
OK. Because I'm not saying
that because of who she is.
She should get punished more.
She should get the punishment
I think once you stab somebody.
What the fuck you doing in the rest of
your life is out the goddamn window.
And I know you guys don't say what they
do that they do that all the time they
fucking take into consideration if people
have children and blah blah blah blah.
Yeah I know they do but the
consideration is a lot smaller.
By the level of tan you have and whether
you have a dick hanging between your
legs or not.
And that's the fucking truth.
Go into a bar.
A woman can slap a guy in the face.
Dump a drink over his fucking head.
She's not getting kicked out.
She's not if she's if she's hot
she's a fucking wildebeest Yeah.
Throw her out in the fucking dumpster.
Come on people this isn't this
isn't new information. All right.
Stop acting like Good Lord. All right.
Why airlines lost their privilege.
Hey Bill.
Big fan.
Love your podcast you recently ask why
airlines are not as prestigious as it was
in the 70s as a pilot.
I have an answer for you I love
when the pilots write in Sky Pilot
why is it still great in 1978.
Hah.
I'm Jim McCone Jimmy Carter signed
the airline deck deregulation act.
Leave it to a peanut farmer from Georgia
to ruin the fucking prestige of airline
train travel.
Prior to this law the government allowed
equal usage of federal airways among
all the airlines. All
right. You're he lost me.
Maybe this law the government allowed
equal usage of federal airways among all
airlines so the only way for airlines
to compete effectively was with good
customer service.
OK.
After the law went into effect airlines
were able to bid for exclusive usage of
certain airways airways are basically
the streets in the sky so different
OK. Oh I see so then and everybody
had their territory so is like.
That's right. There was Eastern
Airlines. They just flew there. OK.
All right. American and United flew
cross country. So it's like wrestling.
Back in the day where everybody had
their territories and then rather than
having one guy
dominate the whole thing like Vince.
It became a bidding war.
OK.
After the law went into effect airlines
were able to bid exclusive usage of
certain airways so airways essentially
gain monopolies on most of their routes
with customers having little or no say
in which airline to take the airlines
were able to get us by the balls.
So now airlines business strategy has
shifted from good customer service to
monopolizing their airways and packing
as many people as possible into their
plane planes.
Hope this helps.
It started too.
What should I look up I should look up
the Airline Deregulation Act now that all
of a sudden in the era of fake news I'm
being suddenly being held accountable
for what the fuck I say.
I can't believe this.
You guys are so disappointing me.
Can somebody please write in and mock
these fucking assholes all right.
Not saying that the pilot here.
All right.
Airline Deregulation Act airline
D Regulation Act Jimmy Carter.
And effects. Let's see what
we got here. Oh my God.
All right.
Whiskey.
The law that changed the airline industry.
That's the one that looks like OK
this is the one I will read up on.
Are you guys going to try to make me
informed and then I'll deny you know what
happens when you know arms
become uniformed he become
an arrogant ass you know
you start smoking a pipe you fuckin
eyebrows are always trying to touch each
other as you wrinkle up you for her. No
one wants to be around that all right.
A law that changed the airline
industry beyond recognition. 1978
okay before deregulation airlines
competed on service alone as fares were
regulated by the government.
I didn't know that.
I mean granted I was fuckin 10 years
old 1970. Many remember this era.
Finally is the golden age of aviation.
When stewardesses.
As flight attendants
were then known carved
I can Chateaubriand on rolling
silver carts and airlines put P.A.
lounges in upper decks of their Boeing
747 as passengers dressed up to board
flights and flying was glamorous and
exciting and mainly for the rich.
That's why the Liberals deregulation
resulted in the rise of a new kind of
airline.
The low cost carrier El Sisi at the time
of deregulation Southwest Airlines was
a small regional airline prevented
by CAIB rules and what that is.
From flying outside of
Texas today Southwest is the
largest domestic US carrier
in terms of passenger traffic something
no one could have foreseen in 1978.
Yeah.
That's back when stewardesses
were fucking hot.
So now it's a bunch of animals they pack
us all in and then it's just like yeah
the heart is like oh fuck this I'm going
to go sell jello shots at a goddamn one
of those deejay shows where baby baby.
Wow wow wow wow wow.
Right. Southwest is a success
story but deregulation allowed.
Yeah I hate flying Southwest.
I fucking hate it you know why I hate
how the stewardesses sit there making
jokes and fucking around it's like
dude my life is in your hands here.
You're not making me more relaxed doing
your fucking Dean Martin impression.
But deregulation allowed airlines to
innovate new business models people people
express.
I remember that number ValuJet that one
went down people express may have come
and gone.
May someday be revived but in others
like it shook up the white glove world of
the US airline industry and
democracies travel hub I said that right.
We may peer through our rose colored
glasses and yearn for the days of Chateau
bring all in piano lounges but ultimate
companies like Southwest and newer ones
like Spirit are allowed more
people to fly more often.
Yeah.
And now look at the result.
You got people with no shoes on
walking into the bathroom. Oh my God.
It all came full circle.
Holy shit do I like being informed.
Deregulation left the international
carriers like Pan Am in Braniff and to a
lesser extent TWC TransWorld Airlines
without robust domestic feeder networks.
What that means and it allowed domestic
carriers like Delta Airlines to apply
for international routes.
Pan Am and Braniff scrambled to create
domestic networks but ultimately were
unsuccessful.
Although it took until 2004 TWC to
be absorbed into American Airlines
some argue that massive consolidation
of the US airline industry in the last
decade which has resulted in three large
carriers for when Southwest is included
is deregulations final act.
The network carriers that survive Delta
United and American learned to be tough
competitors and combined existing
domestic networks with the international
networks acquired in large part by
carriers like Pan Am. That didn't make it.
Get the fuck out.
So now they have to drag
people off flights barefooted
lunatics and then you got
people fucking you know you ever see those
people that just fly around the world
all the time trying to get Miles and shit
just created all these bottom feeders.
Wow do you think a VIP airline
would would make it I wonder
you know in this era of Donald Trump if
they just they if they didn't even try
to be nice just be.
I wish I wish I could do a Trump
impression should be a lot of animals
flying barefoot of here.
And then you know all the liberals have
no idea why you saying it barefooted
people shouldn't be allowed to
let it be your feet a bare feet.
Too Can you.
What if what if they had a fuck that
you couldn't do it nowadays if you had a
fucking top line airline.
Okay all first class seats
all hot stewardesses.
You know first of all all the fucking
you know all the fucking feminists would
be up in arms would all be up in arms
saying that they your objective flying
these women blah blah blah blah blah.
And at the end of the I don't know I agree
with some of that feminist shit but a
lot of times I just feel like it's
women who aren't good looking.
Hating on good looking women and just
being mad that could look and women don't
have to work as hard.
You know
it's like that whole thing that you're
going to somehow get people to give.
Not as good looking women not as good
looking man not as strong men like a
chance it's not how it works you got to
like you gotta look at it like sports
and realize that you're not the Jordan
you're not Sidney Crosby all right.
You're on the fourth line OK so what you
have to be is you have to be a fucking
you've got to be a gamer.
You know.
This is coming from a bald
redheaded male so go fuck yourself.
If you think I'm being elitist here.
OK you got to be scrappy you've
got to go in the corners.
All right you've got to drop the gloves
every so healthy you gotta do that.
OK.
You're not going to get the calls you're
going to have to work 10 times fucking
harder than other people to get you know
half as much over the expression goes
but it's gotta make you stronger.
You know what's great is your
fall from grace from your youth.
6 As you slide into a
four is not that bad.
But at the end of everybody's life
everybody looks like a 4 or 2 OK.
But you have a nice soft landing you do
a little bit of a belly flop you get the
wind knocked out here between 20 and 60.
All right these fucking tense I mean
they've fallen off the top of a goddamn
building. OK then a lot of
them they don't survive it.
They don't if you look at their botox
faces they look like they landed face
first the fucking lips are all swollen.
I mean Jesus Christ look at these fucking
near watches this show and these women
will not stop taking fat from the back
of their arms and injected him in their
ass and they've got these stupid looking
fucking asses now and their legs look
like my legs with this weird
like they look like ostriches.
I don't know why they did that
I just I just don't fucking understand
why they get what point it's like they're
literally like Michael Jackson where
Michael Jackson couldn't see what he's
doing to his face these women cannot
see what they're doing to their asses I
don't understand it.
So anyways you know it was
actually fascinating and I
make fun of the fact that
I'm not a well read guy because it gives
me license to be lazy and that's what I
like to do best.
OK but if you fucking assholes are going
to keep reading I did I did enjoy that
I do enjoy I like drums
shit I like aviation I like
that type of shit all right.
So if you're going to fucking really
start hold my feet to the fire here.
Could you please try to keep it.
Well I guess I have the
power right I have the power.
Where I can actually decide.
What the fuck it is that I want to
read or what I don't want to read.
Speaking of which for some reason I
woke up this morning thinking about Roy
Haynes and the fact that he's still
alive and still doing gigs and all the
fucking people he's played with.
Like I saw a bunch of great jazz
drummers before they passed.
I saw Max Roach I saw Tony Williams.
I saw Louis Belson.
And I saw Roy Haynes.
I saw Roy Haynes like 20 something years
ago and he's in his 70s is now 92 and I
looked it up like this
guy's still on the road.
He's got a road gig
coming up in September.
Like the Blue Note in New York City
he's from Roxbury Massachusetts.
Fellow Boston guy I'm a suburb guy.
He's actually in Boston but
I don't think that's pretty fucking
cool the guy's still gigging out there.
Manitoba guy he played with Charlie
Parker Miles Davis Sarah Vaughan Chloe all
the way up right up through
like young people today.
The guy's been playing drums
professionally for 70 goddamn years.
So I don't know if you're into drums
you've got to go see that guy. All right.
Let me go.
We read some more of the
All right.
Let me read these last two cultural
appropriation. Dear Billy rationale.
Things are getting crazy these
days because of technology
it's definitely a lot
easier to be critical
of what everyone does.
I'm sure you've experienced this before
where people try and misrepresent what
you say for whatever self-serving
reason they may have.
Yes of course that would
be the Huffington Post.
One of the things going on today that
really bugs me is the accusation of
cultural appropriation.
I hate picking extreme sides to any
arguments so I will say I do think that
there are cases of cultural disrespect.
Let's say someone wears a religious or
cultural garb and is overly disrespectful
for the purpose of trolling that could
be that could be cultural appropriation.
You put that in quotes.
So do you not think it is but almost
everything anyone does is derived from
another culture in some respect.
There is a YouTube video where a young
black college girl berates a hippie for
his cornrows and it seems a bit silly
because the kid is just doing what every
other walkies who listen to fish do.
I don't know what a wookie is.
There's somebody into Chewbacca now.
Fuck now I got to look this up.
What the fuck is a wookie
a white something wookie meaning slang.
A wookie urban dictionary a wookie a
wookie is a hairy yet modernised human
being that commonly is seen in the
western in the western most regions of
Washington a gentle creature by nature
but tends to get a little erratic when it
overindulge itself with its favorite
foods its diet consists mainly of a blend
of barley and hops.
If you see these creatures
be cautious as to whether you should
provide him with these items they will
commonly respond to the name of Richard
Pulliam but be very wary of these
creatures.
I have no idea.
They're usually um remember a certain
brand of cookie that is very chewy.
A wookie is a lifeless idiot whose whole
existence consists of falling around
jam bands.
Here we go and not showering or shaving
when they're not panhandling or trying
to rip people off.
They're selling veggie burritos a grilled
cheese to fund their useless existence.
They stand for nothing and
care about nobody else.
Not to be confused with a hippie AP As
someone who lives a certain lifestyle due
to their belief 50s often shower and have
jobs used in a sentence shows yo those
walkies over there are
trying to sell beat rolls.
That's from fucking 2003. So I guess
they've been around for a while.
OK
all right let me get back to that.
OK so now you know what a wookie is
and what a wookie is and I know about
airline deregulation and now I'm going
to be insufferable the next fuckin social
event is I try to work both of
those into the conversation.
Where the fuck is it
I was an anthropology major.
Which doesn't make me an expert but it
definitely informs my opinion of this.
I went to culinary school after college
and learned even more about cultures
through their food.
I came up upon this article and
wanted to get your take upon it.
Take a couple girls in Portland Oregon
started a food truck selling Mexican food.
They traveled around and learned recipes
the way every chef I've ever known has
done. They were accused of cultural
appropriation because they're not Mexican.
I'm not going to go on a tirade of mother
fucker mother fucks but my adrenaline
really starts going
when I think about this.
I haven't heard you speak about cultural
appropriation yet and wanted to get
your take. Here's a link.
Oh the Huffington Post.
What a fucking surprise.
Thanks for your podcast.
You're a great dad and husband.
How do you know that you have no idea.
I hate the fucking Huffington Post.
They're always trying
to stir up some shit.
You know I hate all these organizations
that try to act like they're their news
organization and you read two articles
and you know who everybody on the website
voted for essentially. It's like back in
the day like it was supposed to be. No
fewer journalists you were supposed
to just sort of present what the fuck
happened not making up.
If you say this.
That's probably because you're doing that.
That's like that whole fucking web site
and I shouldn't just single them out.
There's a bunch of them out there and
but they're held in like this esteem.
I just don't understand it
anyways. Cultural appropriation is
I don't fucking know.
You know look if you if you have an
appreciation for Mexican food you still
learn how to cook it and then you sell it.
I think at that point if
you become successful that's
when people get annoyed by
it.
And college kids are really extreme.
In their thoughts as I do you know you're
fucking breaking free of your parents.
You know when you got some anger issues
probably towards your parents so you're
very you're very open to
radical fucking sort of ideas.
You know going all the way over here
all the way over there it's a very
dangerous time in your life because
you make very extreme judgements snap
judgment calls with your young brain
as I did and that can cause you
to do stupid shit like join cults.
Blow yourself up at a fucking concert
you know for some stupid fucking cause.
All the way to like I don't know what
fucking without a condom you know you just
it's pretty fucking wild thing.
This is why I don't talk
about shit like this.
I don't know what a cultural
appropriation is. I don't know what it is.
I know is that my culture is the matrix.
So everybody's allowed you know I don't
get upset when people get on airplanes
B.A.
that's some white shit you know.
I would say that if they're two white
girls being white and they're making great
fucking Mexican food good for them
but if they're sitting there wearing a
fucking sombrero and talking like
speeding Gonzalez when they do it. Yeah.
Then I would get upset but you know
there's plenty of Asian infused this and
French and fuse that and
cultures to me and all of that shit to me.
It's like.
It's like the MMI
how is how was like How good were the
martial arts when it was you would just
want discipline.
You know everyone I I I am a Kito I am
fucking taekwondo I do karate I fucking
box or whatever.
And then a guy Bruce Lee comes around
he's like I'll take a little dance I'll
take a little of that wasn't
he doing that you know.
And then he was teaching it to fucking
the round eyed guys over here and
everybody over in Asia is
like hey that's our shit.
Don't be showing it to their shit and
now look at it now look how great the
fuckin fighters are.
You know what I mean.
I would love to see Bruce Lee today if
he beat him back then if he got into the
fuckin ring you know what I mean.
Did he ever have to deal with a double
legged takedown what would happen to him.
Does he have a ground and pound
defense ground and pound didn't exist.
Could that man fight on his back.
That's how much it's progressed so I feel
everything should get all fuckin mixed
up and then shit spins
out of that easy just like
I think it's just when you start to act
like you're the thing that you're doing.
You know what I mean like
people do.
But the thing is is if you start
getting into like like whatever Japanese
cuisine
OK or you get into anime or whatever
I'm watching this anime show like I just
watch it and I appreciate it.
I don't start walking around with the
rising sun fucking T-shirt and I get some
swords criss crossed on my walls you
know starts sitting on the floor and a
pillow with a little short table.
You know what I mean.
I mean where I don't know
I don't know where you are.
I think it's all how you do it.
I mean I walk into an Asian person's
house and they've got a bunch of shit from
Ikea.
I don't go like you know you're
appropriating my culture.
What's what that L shaped couch
but they're also not a pressing
me and I'm not pressing anybody.
But overall the fuck and you
know a longtime concept to top.
Ah so that's what it really
comes down to it really.
I think it really comes down to why
people get held to that standard of of
cultural appropriation because you know
we can the damage we can do and we can
be really ignorant with it and then
other times people are just being country
like I'm not going to read this fucking
article but if it's just a couple of
white chicks make Mexican food they're
crushing it you know and they're dressed
like White Chicks going like
Oh my God who wants a burrito.
I don't think there's a problem with
that if they're killing it right.
It's a fucking food truck fill
your pie hole up and shadow.
All right girlfriend
Hey man what's up.
I just we had a few questions.
Sorry for the lack of punctuation.
We'll use parentheses when he said that.
I flew this girl out all the way to Japan.
You know something.
Fuck you I'm not reading this shit.
You this you want you
rewrite this fucking thing.
You rewrite this fucking thing okay.
And then I'll read it. Go fuck yourself.
Sorry for the lack of punctuation. Yes
I am not fucking pregnant. There you go.
I draw the line at lack of punctuation.
I hate when people fucking go.
Sorry if you're sorry you would've taken
the time to to put some shit in there.
You didn't. You're not sorry
you're fucking lazy so fuck off.
Now I'm going to be lazy right back
to you and I read your goddamn shit.
However if you want to fix it put some
punctuation in and I will read it.
God damn it I will read it all right.
The Red Sox
were in second place and the evil
empire Yankees are in first place.
Those evil mother fuckers with
all their homegrown talent.
And here we are the young upstarts with
a 250 million dollar team just doing
anything we can to try
to keep up with them.
I want to know I want to fucking know
because I already lost a bunch of weight.
I know we end up getting
fucking hurt again.
I want to know when Pablo's coming back.
I don't know why I just feel like he's
going to have a great second half of the
season.
Pablo Sandoval and he's going
to earn his goddamn money.
I think the Red Sox are good they're
gonna catch fire here right before the
All-Star break and it's gonna be
Yankees Red Sox Yankees Red Sox.
It's gonna be great again it's gonna be
fucking hilarious because now we're the
fucking evil empire that could
spend it to win a fucking million dollars.
That's my prediction.
It's gonna go down to them.
And
ESPN will blow the Yankees because they
have homegrown talent and they will
fucking trash the Red Sox for spending
all this fucking money like they never
trashed the Yankees when they did it back
in the day because that's how it works
because when the Yankees win the World
Series ESPN goes in all is right in the
baseball universe. It's just like Oh
so you guys are all Yankee fans there.
Why does it make it right.
I never understood that that they play
favorites like that but I guess that's
what they do. So you know
what. Fuck them fuck you too.
Have a great couple of days I'll
check in on you on Thursday.
Be careful around those
grills you have fatties.